but we thought Dana was going to
announce UFC 300 Main Event and co-main
event today but he didn't do any of that
he announced that McGregor Chandler's
not happening it's not happening in June
this is what my skeptical hippo eyes
think McGregor has one or two fights
left on his contract the UFC never lets
you fight your contract out especially
if you're a mega star like Conor Manny
Pacquiao's coming out of retirement his
number one opponent he wants to fight is
McGregor I think Conor's like yeah I
just need to fight Chandler and I'm
going to fight Manny Pacquiao and UFC's
like no you're not you only have one or
two fights left we we need to figure out
a new deal with you and he's like no I
don't want to do that I want to fight
Chandler I'm going to fight Manny
Pacquiao probably Jake Paul maybe Nate
Diaz in boxing that's what I want to do
UFC is going no way we can't let you go
I think it'd be a flex on Dana's part
too to do it because remember he
wouldn't let Francis do it what do you
think sells more more Francis Fury which
didn't do great or Conor Manny Pacquiao
so I think there's a lot going on behind
the scenes we're not privy to